[Music]
once sex was strictly rule-governed now
casual sex is a default option and even
publications like teen vogue run
features on bdsm and anal sex yet large
surveys in the uk and the us have found
actual sex in decline across all age
groups and millennials twice as likely
to be having no sex than their parents
of the same age is the decline in sex
the disturbing outcome of our inability
to form relationships in an internet age
that has supposedly made it so simple or
is this a positive sign that sex toys
and porn are liberating us from
unfulfilling sex might the future of sex
even be outside of our primary
relationships together to help us
navigate our way through we're joined by
ella whelan a political commentator
freelance journalist and author of what
women want fun freedom and an end to
feminism olivia fale is a writer and in
her most recent book why sex doesn't
matter she addresses the politics the
obsessions the misconceptions of sex
so magosh is a cultural critic performer
and founding editor of cult polysexual
magazine the demented goddess we're
going to ask each of our speakers to set
out their stall to have a a pitch if you
like and they'll get three minutes each
so the question we're asking them to
address is
is there a right type of sex life
and i'm gonna ask ella to kick us off
thank you and sean in short is there a
right kind of sex life broadly no but i
think that we're being increasingly told
that there is a right kind of sex to
have and that there is a right kind of
or
moral kind of sexual life to inhabit
and i think that's an entirely negative
thing i think in many ways
especially for young people
um the idea of what constitutes a good
and healthy sex life looks more and more
like a kind of
puritanical almost victorian view of sex
and something that has to be quite
heavily policed and quite heavily
fraught with um worries and concerns and
pressures and i think that's a very
negative thing it's fascinating that
surveys
from all different kinds of places bmj
and more informal ones show that
millennials are having less sex in
particular and obviously in part i think
that can be explained by some very
obvious things
like there are less pubs and clubs open
social life and meeting in bars has
changed um obviously the advent of
technology and dating apps and all the
things has their knock-on effect but i
think actually it's a it's
much more important an issue is the fact
that we are talking about sex seeing sex
more often than ever before it's
everywhere and it's not just kind of in
magazines and on billboards but it's in
school it's
parents talk about it to their kids
we're much much much more open
about sex and yet we're not having
seemingly we're not having as much sex
and for women in particular i think the
reason why this is happening is that and
this is what i go into in the book what
women want that a contemporary feminist
politics is i think really
kind of stirring up a huge amount of
fear around sex
treating sex lives especially for women
as very troubled dangerous places that
are to be
approached with caution rather than an
exciting part of
adult life whether that be you know
scaremongering um about a so-called rape
culture on university campuses in the uk
and america
a broadening idea of what sexual
harassment constitutes beyond any kind
of sensible recognition um or also this
kind of obsession with consent in a way
that doesn't reflect reality but
actually problematizes the possibility
to have any kind of spontaneous or
enjoyable sexual experience without
worrying about whether you're literally
breaking the law i'll just finish on the
point that i think the most depressing
part of this for me
is that i think
women lose out on this most because it
is our sex lives that have already
always been historically scrutinized
and continue to be scrutinized in fact
by cam political campaigns and policies
which claim to be
speaking in our favor feminist or
otherwise you know the push for consent
classes means that it takes away the
agency of a woman to be able to
you know know and understand what her
lines are without having it dictated to
you by some kind of person in official
dom that i think the obsession with um
self-pleasuring there's other words for
it that i'm not hip enough to mention
but
masturbation with kind of being alone
with yourself and self-care as it's
called that i think is incredibly
alienating and also puts a lot of
pressure on uh women to not be able to
experiment and i think
in some ways ironically the massive push
to destigmatize sex and just have it
talked about ad nauseam has maybe taken
some of the fun out of it and i think
that in really my sort of thesis has
been i think if we leave people alone
more about sex it might mean that we
start getting back together and getting
it on because i think we're too much in
our own individual sense of what we
consider a sex life to be and not going
out there enough and experimenting with
real sex and real sex lives thank you
ella so
politics
the politically right sort of sex
puritanism and pressure
olivia
is there a right type of sex life
this is the right type of sex life
two 15-minute periods of sexual
intercourse per week
nothing beyond the missionary position
and nothing which might incite lust or
transgress god's purpose to have very
large families
thus recommended the victorians in their
sex manuals
we
laugh at them
we quite sure the victorians were wrong
our own language is quite different we
believe in the freedom to sexually
express ourselves
no
right type of sex life for us
we are true to our desires true to our
feelings our fantasies we are so free
yet are we are we really free
the social obligation is to have a
really great sex life filled with danger
excitement spice to prove that we are
not repressed or frigid to prove that we
are exciting people
is as harsh as any stipulation by the
victorians
so it turns out that even though we say
there isn't a right type of sex life
actually it turns out there really is
and if you're not having bucket loads of
pleasure then you're a failure
my father-in-law was a painter
i once asked him why he barely used the
color red in his painting
you told me that the color was so bright
it distracted from the beauty of the
other colors
sex is like the color red
it draws us in like a magnet our eye
irresistibly rests on it
and because it does
we moderns have given sex meanings it
simply doesn't have
perhaps there are couples watching this
who want to argue with me sex is an
expression of love they say
sexual pleasure is a really important
part of marriage
of life
if you are such a couple oh my goodness
how i looked for you before i began
researching my book
i was humble
before i began researching i promise you
i did not know the answer i did not know
i needed to know i wanted people to show
me how sex and love really fitted
together
or even
why
pleasure mattered
why does pleasure matter it seemed weird
but i wanted to learn and i was humble
the first time i interviewed a couple
was not good
it was informal their friends not close
friends they came for a summer dinner
and i looked at them in the eye and i
said for example what does sex mean
to you two
the women immediately answered
love of course
and the man answered
alas simultaneously
and with equal enthusiasm
release
they began to argue
are you going gonna tell me that sex has
never meant more to you than pleasure is
just a bunk it's just a shag it's
nothing spiritual in it is that is that
really really what you feel about our
nights of sex together is that really
what you feel she said there was no
placating her
two weeks later
they separated
but is that rather sad story exceptional
doesn't sex mean something entirely
different to every one of us
so
is there a right type of sex life
well the whole phrase a right type um
smacks of approval doesn't it when we
say that somebody is the right type we
mean that they are one of us um and what
we want to do generally uh with the the
kind of fanfare and shock around these
surveys is to flatten and categorize sex
um so that it fits a model that is
productive um productive sex is
primarily heterosexual it's vaginal um
hence the uh we're supposed to be
shocked
at bdsm or anal sex
um it's productive sex that produces
um family tickets um family bags of
crisps
seats for couples and moral order so i'd
agree uh with ella
um that a lot of talk about sex in this
apparently age of greater freedom is um
curiously or perhaps not um extremely
moralistic and prescriptive and yes that
it impacts on women um whose sexuality
she said has always been policed um and
and on queers and on anybody who doesn't
uh fit
this uh defecation of the dyad the you
know the holy couple
and that's not new as olivia pointed out
um with the victorian prescription for
large families and it doesn't matter
which side of the victor of the uh
political spectrum you're on either so
even shelley and that great radical and
um you know referred a great deal to by
uh new labor um who was an atheist a
vegetarian a propagator of unmarried
love even he and his beautiful
uh poem loves philosophy um she presents
this sort of holistic model of stability
where the waves clasp one another the
mountains clasp one another um each you
know each sister flower should most
definitely um kiss her brother no no no
worries about um ella's point about
consent um what is all this sweet work
worth if thou kiss not me um so even
radicals are interested in the work of
policing sex
um of stabilizing it
um um
so so so
so in short obviously not the right i
know to the idea of the right type and
what i find more interesting
um is
sex that is
or rather an experience of sex the
allowance of the experience of sex that
might be imaginative that might be
malleable according to your environment
according to um moments in your life and
we know this from the studies of people
like dr lisa richmond who coined the
term female sexual fluidity i was back
in 2000 and in the last decade has been
mapping male sexual fluidity as well
um i'm also interested in sex that
disrupts this exhausting vision of the
so-called sex life i mean what you know
what the hell's a sex life it's like the
sex life uh you're going to do it with
this one person you're on this train now
and you're doing this particular way
because it's a life life has a journey
life has got to have a meaning and
you're on this train until it crashes
through just you know death or
unsustainability
so i'm much more interested in
love that is not necessarily productive
but that expands our erotic imagination
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you